PETER QUILL
We were gone for quite a while.
♪♪
But no matter
what happens next,
the galaxy still
needs its Guardians.
PETER QUILL
Hello! We come in peace.
[Alien giggles]
[Crowd gasps]
PETER QUILL
Come on Drax, seriously dude?
ALIEN
Nodu nada!
PETER QUILL
Ow!
DRAX
[Laughing] Hey!
[Screaming]
♫ "In The Meantime"
by Spacehog ♫
MANTIS
Don't forget...
...where we came from.
PETER QUILL
We have been running...
...our whole lives.
ROCKET
Pete, I'm done running.
♫ We love the all,
the all of you ♫
♫ Where lands are green
and skies are blue ♫
ROCKET
We'll all fly away together...
One last time...
♫ We love the all of you ♫
ROCKET
...into the forever,
...and beautiful sky.
♪♪
GROOT
We are Groot!
♪♪
♫ We love the all,
the all of you ♫
DRAX
And we'll kill anyone who gets in our way!
PETER QUILL
No, not kill anyone.
DRAX
Kill a few people.
PETER QUILL
Kill no people.
DRAX
Kill one guy. One stupid guy,
who no one loves.
PETER QUILL
Now you're just making it sad.